[Music]
the way that you that you shown kill
zombies on the show your it's so it's
almost like ballet what you're so good
at it you're so good at it and you've
really and you're really the physicality
of what you do with your Sabre you're so
good at it that it feels like it's
carefully worked out and choreographed
but I was told that it's just one scene
that I remember in particular that I
really loved and I found out that no
that that was you improvising they that
you just sort of freestyled that scene
of killing zombies is that true yeah
that was a season 4 episode 9 which I so
enjoyed that episode was with the great
Greg Nicotero directing he's also an EP
he's also in charge of all the zombies
so aka the man and so when he decides
we're not gonna cut we don't cut so I've
been told you can kill you know it's
killing zombies costs you know it costs
the budget so there's a certain amount
you're allowed to kill right so I was
told I could kill eight come on there
are two dozen here they're like eight
deny so we'd worked out eight so there
was eight kills I was allowed to do and
those I'd worked out exactly how I was
gonna do it with the stunt coordinator
and then we did the eight and then mr.
Nicotero just did not call cut so I just
kept going and and you killed I think up
to 24
I love it to declare it was really funny
and you know it's great people love that
scene and one fan is both a Walking Dead
fan he's also a Star Wars fan so he
spent a lot of time and he replaced your
weapon with a lightsaber and put it on
the line I don't know if you this is
what it is it's really cool
[Music]
[Applause]
also I'm just curious like zombies just
don't learn that's the mistake they see
35 other guys get taken out of the light
maybe I'll get through I feel like I'll
have better luck
you